[Music]
there is no doubt Luke Combs has taken
the country world by storm since the
release of his debut single hurricane in
2015 now nearly five years later he's
earned himself seven consecutive number
ones his second album
what-you-see-is-what-you-get debuted at
number one on the country chart and he
was inducted into the Grand Ole Opry all
before the age of 30 so to celebrate
Luke's milestone birthday in March
second we're rounding up his top ten
songs back
last year
the thing seen
sure
[Music]
[Applause]
who ever seen
[Music]
never me
[Music]
[Music]
inside
[Music]
I'll be right by your side when you need
and
the night
[Music]
dancing record
the can dance all in the first we're in
three two too many
to sit
here's down
five days
they got to me
[Music]
she buys me
[Applause]
what's left
beach vacation
[Applause]
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
crazies she can
amazed me
the way the cheat dances ain't afraid to
take chances and where's her harshly
yes she's crazy
[Music]
Crazy's beautiful
so did all your favorites make the list
let us know in the comments below
[Music]
Oh